[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
fällt meine lieben freunde hier vorne
sehen wir den leuchtturm wir haben hier
vorne das portal schwert wir haben die
zauberinsel und wenn wir mal nach dort
hinten schauen sehen wir dort hinten
auch die kirche die wir in der letzten
folge fertiggestellt haben es sieht
alles extrem schön aus ich werde zu
beginn erst mal ganz kurz das feld hier
vorne fällen sagte reinfeldt fällen dass
das fett abbauen und natürlich auch
wieder schnell bepflanzen so dass das
weizen hier weiter wachsen kann
allerdings kümmern wir uns heute um
[Musik]
richtig da wurde um die monster falle da
haben wir hier hinten einen spieler
gefunden und in der heutigen episode
möchte ich das ding ja nicht mal fertig
stellen
von daher euch eine ganz große teile die
ich mir die materialien zusammen sammeln
[Musik]
so und dass wir jetzt auch fertig meine
lieben freunde schaut mal wie geil das
aussieht wenn man hier vorne aus unserer
kisten für rausgeht und dahinter die
kirche eingeblendet sieht hier vorne
auch mit unserem fischerhäuschen da
waren wir noch gar nicht so richtig
angehen allerdings brauchen wir dafür ja
erstmal ein paar level um unsere angel
zu verzaubern und diese level bekommen
wir dadurch dass wir jetzt dort hinten
zu unserer monster falle jetzt mal
hinfahren mit unserem brötchen das macht
glaube ich am meisten sinn wir könnten
auch einfach mal kurz mit meinen
kartfahren war auch schon länger nicht
gemacht hier vorne
seht ihr ja die strandhaus villa die
wollen wir in der nächsten folge ein
bisschen weiter bauen
da werde ich mich dann darauf
konzentrieren wir wieder in die hölle zu
gehen und ein bisschen qua zu fahren da
dass er mit dem trading mit den willen
nicht so richtig geklappt hat allerdings
werde ich jetzt erstmal auf höhe der
situation hier vorne aussteigen und
meinte wir sehen uns dann später einfach
wieder dass er jetzt erst mal kurz hier
über schwimmen das problem ist
allerdings dass wir gleich auf jeden
fall bei der mob falle die ich bauen
möchte oben wieder rauskommen werden
deswegen werde ich jetzt erstmal ganz
kurz hier vorne alles zu bauen wir haben
ja immer noch das problem dass hier
wenigstens kann ich schon mal wieder ab
wer mir vor nicht immer noch das problem
dass das wasser oben nicht so richtig
abfliesst deswegen werde ich das einfach
mal erde hinsetzen und das klappt
überhaupt nicht ich mache jetzt einfach
mal so und nehmen nun meine erde hier
runter und baue ich ja alles zu so dass
das jetzt eigentlich klappen sollte wenn
ich jetzt jährliche vorne wieder abbauen
kann ich nämlich ganz easy einfach neue
leitern hinsetzen die ich mir nehme ich
vorhin auch schon gemacht habe und dann
haben wir jetzt hier auch einen
vernünftigen gang von oben bis unten und
und uns vernünftig fortbewegen von der
mob falle unten hoch zu unserem ausgang
die sache ist da allerdings auch dass
ich das hier unten erst mal ganz kurz
nochmal abbauen muss und mir auch
generell hier vorne noch mal eben zwei
zähler holen muss den ganzen kram
benötigen wir für die beförderungs
mechanik der skelette die dann hier
sport und dann runter gehen und dann
übersehen sind übers wasser hoch und
dann werden so runter gedrückt da muss
ich noch einmal schlagen und dann sind
sie tot und wir haben eine menge
experience unmenge items allerdings muss
ich hier erst mal einen 99 großes feld
abbauen und dann fünf blöcke nach oben
[Musik]
von leute 2 max hier leute trotzdem
streiten
ich kam zum streit
ich will einfach nur ganz kurz herüber
um schlafen zu gehen und mir steckt auch
ein fall
ich wollte einfach nur kurz rüber gehen
um ein bisschen glas noch mitzunehmen
was ich noch benötigt habe was ich
vorhin vergessen habe ich glaube das
habe ich hier oben gehen oder nicht hier
oben drin 550 glas sollten auf jeden
fall ausreichen und ich kann noch ein
paar sachen schon mal eben kurz hier
lassen die ich noch vorne gleich erstmal
nicht mehr benötigen werde
die sache ist allerdings ist dann
einfach direkt so ein blöder creeper
ankamen
jetzt haben wir hier eine blöde
situation und hier vorne haben wir das
auch und läutet freibergs hier hast du
dir auch wirklich nicht ausdenken
das kannst du dir doch wirklich nicht
ausdenken läutet beim export hat das ist
mir jetzt auch komplett egal ich leider
nur ganz kurze times einen wie ich den
ersten schritt der monster falle
fertigbauen nicht auf der so einfach zu
finden
[Musik]
so sieht das jetzt hier wurde erst mal
aus ich habe hier ein bisschen glas
hingesetzt denn das hier vorne ist ja
unser weg nach oben in die freiheit
und dann werde ich gucken dass ich dann
hier nachher den weg über sätze davor
das bonn schon die ersten skelette
obwohl das ding fast komplett
ausgeleuchtet ist eigentlich allerdings
seht ihr schon dass ich hier vorn ein
wasser gesetzt habe und hier denn die
skelette spawnen dann hier rutschen dann
quasi hier runter und gehen hier vorne
hin
ich werde allerdings oben auf den
spanner drauf noch einen allerdings
setzten eine glatte steinstufen so dass
keine skelette oben auf dem sportler
drauf sich setzen und dementsprechend
dann ja dort oben einfach schilder
allerdings seht ihr schon das ganze
funktioniert ich bewege nichts und ich
bewege mich quasi hierüber in einen
kleinen gang den ich je gemacht habe
hier habe ich zolle hingesetzt und hier
einen blog und jetzt werden wir von hier
27 blöcken nach oben gehen und da ist
das problem dass wir wahrscheinlich in
den ozean gelangen werden so jetzt sind
wir hier leider schon oben angekommen
ich glaube mal ganz kurz nach oben so
dass ich ein bisschen frische luft eben
atmen kann der sc bolsterlang dem
leuchtturm kirche ganz hinten können wir
gar nicht erkennen allerdings seht ihr
schon ich habe eine verkehrs man die
linke hand genommen so dass wir ein
bisschen beleuchtung hier haben genau
hier müssen wir jetzt darüber gehen
jetzt muss ich mal ganz kurz überlegen
wenn das hier ist fließt das wasser
quasi so hier rüber das heißt wir müssen
ganz überlegen also hier vorne ist jetzt
unser eingang und dementsprechend habe
ich jetzt hier unten einfach mal das
hier so gebaut so dass ich mich jetzt
hier mal eben kurz einbauen kann
für mich ganz groß eben runter bauen
kann und nur hier oben dann die blöcke
so hinsetzen so dass das wasser als
erstmal weg kommt das wasser geht nicht
weg doch okay das was als auf jeden fall
weg jedoch müssen wir jetzt genau hier
vorne neuen wasser einmal hinsetzen und
uns dann ganz schnell die eben schnell
runter bauen
oh gott ich weiß nicht ob das passiert
ich muss auf jeden fall mein gott nein
das ist jetzt nicht wahr das ist jetzt
nicht das ist jetzt nicht das ist nicht
wahr ist auch stressig so was zu bauen
hier mit mode sehr nebenan hier vorne
setzen wir jetzt einfach neue steine hin
und bauen uns hier noch mal ganz schnell
den weg geben nach unten so dass das
ganze dann so aus wenn wir unten
angekommen sind so war das allerdings
nicht haben deswegen setzen hier ganz
kurz ein erdloch hin und damit das
wasser nicht integriert mit dem wasser
hier packen wir hier einfach zwei
schilder dran so dass wenn wir nun in
der blockabwehr herzinfarkt bekommen
wegen zum blöden skeletten war soll dann
auf jeden fall so aussehen wir nehmen
nun allerdings unseren vätern und
setzten den von unten nach oben einmal
durch müssen dementsprechend wieder
schnell nach oben schwimmen nun bauen
wir allerdings den see teil wieder ab
und ersetzt in unseren ehrt block mit
einem seelen so dass hier unten das seht
ihr wenn ich hier ganz bisschen drauf
gehe
einige blasen auftreten hier nach oben
gehen dass schleudert uns ziemlich
extrem krass nach oben wir müssen hier
allerdings erst bei jetzt einen blog
entfernen und nun seht ihr schon dass
wir quasi hier vorne rüber gekleidet
werden und dann direkt nach oben
geschickt werden also so eine art
fahrstuhl nun bauen wir hier vorne
allerdings zwei blöcken ab und gehen ein
wenig rüber in diese richtung hier und
nun muss ich ein bisschen erfinderisch
werden denn das war eigentlich nicht
geplant dass das hier direkt im ozean
stattfindet jedoch sind wir da einfach
mal kurz erfinderischen bauen hier vorne
sondern kleine tunnel der genau bis
hierhin geht und hier vorne dann auch
eine wand beziehungsweise gehe ich noch
mal ganz kurz hochheben atmen da das
hier unter wasser echt mal ein bisschen
kritisch ist allerdings können wir schon
sehen der leuchtturm da hinten leuchtet
wir haben hier vorne noch immer die
höhle die wir doch immer nicht zu ende
durchsucht haben allerdings zeige ich
euch jetzt erst mal ganz kurz wie ich
mir das hier unten vorgestellt habe denn
wir müssen hier jetzt erst mal kurz
alles zubauen den ganzen tunnel apparat
zack zack und hier vorne jetzt auch mal
kurz das gras abbauen so dass wir hier
auch das ganze wasser erstmal entfernung
vernünftig atmen können das seht ihr
unten rechts das sieht echt aus interner
whirlpool das wird mir damals auch
irgendwann in die kommentare geschrieben
dass das eigentlich ganz neues wäre wenn
ich das auch bei meiner strandhaus will
also machen würde
wir setzen nun allerdings hier ans ende
erst mal ein schild so dass ihr seht
dass das wasser nur bisher fließt und
man quasi hier hoch gelegt wird und dann
hier rüber und hier wieder runter fällt
und nun bauen wir uns von hier vorne
genau 23 blöcke nach unten sonst von 23
also hier vorne sollen die monster auf
jeden fall ankommen
dementsprechend gehen wir jetzt noch
einen block weiter runter und dann
setzen wir hier einen trick dahin so
dass wir genau wissen ich hier fallen
die monster drauf und sind quasi warhead
gegner also ich kann sie nur einmal
schlagen und sie sterben direkt und
diesen trichter verbinden wir nur dann
auch direkt geht aber schon die kamen an
und ich muss auch einmal schlagen und
dann sind sie tot diesen trichter
verbinden wir jetzt allerdings mit
dieser kiste das hatte ich ja zu beginn
irgendwann mal falsch gemacht seht ihr
allerdings gerade auch schon dass dort
die items rauskamen paar knochen und so
und wir werden auch diese kiste hier
noch mit einer weiteren kiste verbinden
ja dann ist erst mal kurz das gold
mitnehmen
dafür setzen wir jetzt nämlich einfach
hier eine truhe hin und hier so dass die
beiden miteinander verbunden sind und
dem trichter hier so an der seite dran
platzieren sodass dort nichts passieren
und nichts danebengehen kann nun machen
wir uns hier vorne einfach einen kleinen
raum neben da war das gerät so sieht das
ganze hier vorne jetzt aus ich habe hier
auch nochmal so glatte steinstufen
darunter gesetzt so dass die monster
nicht wenn ihr ein blog wehre mich auch
attackieren können
hier fallen sie dann drauf hier vorne
kommen dann items sein und hier hier
vorn da habe ich ein trichter neuer
hingesetzt und hier der trailer seht ihr
auch schon geht hier in die kiste rein
hier vorne ist unser zugang zu dem spawn
bereich also hier kann ich das auch noch
mal ganz kurz ebenso vernünftige bauen
denn wir haben ja hier vorne auch noch
den den ganzen höheren gang wo wir hin
müssen da könnte ich theoretisch auch
meine tür hinsetzen ich habe jetzt
allerdings gerade leider nicht die
materialien dafür mit deswegen lassen
das jetzt erst mal ganz kurz so
provisorisch offen
und hier gehen wir jetzt mal ganz kurz
in den sportbereich rein und müssen nun
ganz easy einfach die fackeln entfernen
und ich mich dann gleich hier ganz
schnell an der seite wieder hoch bauen
so dass wir einmal zack machen und hier
folgt aber schon direkt attackiert hier
zeigt und sagt dann sehen wir schon hier
vorne das kletter taktiert mich wird
allerdings zurückgezogen in das ding
rein wieso
ach ich hier noch wünscht er auf jeden
fall kommen die dann hier vorne hin und
jetzt habe ich sie schon getötet
deswegen gehe ich mal ganz schnell raus
und zeigt euch das von der seite hier
vorne hier ist auf jeden fall keine
fackel mehr drin von der vorne kommt ein
bisschen licht rein das müssen wir jetzt
vielleicht überdenken oder vielleicht
klappt es auch so ich weiß noch nicht
genau
ich gehe allerdings ganz kurz war eben
wieder rein und jetzt müssen wir noch
warten bis hier die monster ankommen
[Musik]
die hinter ihnen wie fest ich weiß nicht
was ich falsch gemacht habe
[Musik]
also das ist ja unser eingang der von
oben nach unten runtergeht und ich habe
jetzt mal hier einfach glas lang gesetzt
so dass wir so ein bisschen immer runter
gucken können schauen ob da was sport
allerdings funktioniert das halt auch
alles hier vorne schießen die splatter
eigentlich nach oben und hier fallen sie
dann halt wieder runter das habe ich
jetzt mal mit lars ein bisschen gemacht
damit ein bisschen zu gucken können
und da können wir über die leiter runter
gehen und sehen halt wie die skelette
die sache so dass hier kein skelett
ankommt und ich glaube das liegt daran
dass ich da oben die blöcke kurz weg
genommen habe um dort glas hin zu setzen
deswegen muss ich mich wohl oder übel
noch mal hier rein bewegen und erst mal
ganz kurz den spanner aus bräuchten so
dass wir hier keinen großen stress
bekommen mit irgendwelchen monstern da
werde ich direkt schon abgeschossen
hier fordert schild nämlich auch ernst
gerät das funktioniert alles ist wird
hoch gelegt allerdings wenn wir irgendwo
oder haben
die dia de
[Musik]
gut wie mache ich das jetzt ich glaube
das einfachste ist wenn ich ganz kurz
dem blog er setzte durch erde dann
fallen die ganzen pfeile runter und die
ganze skelette kommen auch und ich kann
jetzt mal alle einmal ganz kurz
[Musik]
alter
ihr seht auf jeden fall die fahrer
funktioniert noch nicht richtig
allerdings
habe mir eine menge skelette auf jeden
fall das ist schon einmalig hier um auf
diese ganzen feine da unten
sie sind alle tot ich mache mal ganz
kurz wohnblock in einer was er denn
dadurch jetzt allein bekommen komme ich
überhaupt darauf ja komm ich zeig wir
haben allein dadurch zwei echten
ausraster wir machen das ganze jetzt
noch einmal neu und setzten jede menge
seetang hin bis nach ganz oben so dass
wir dann nach dann den sälen sand unten
platzieren können also genau bis hier
fordert den see tallinn hier klappt
alles hier gehen dann runter also ich
hier mal ganz kurz wieder hin
jetzt schnell shift gedrückt halten dass
ich nach ganz unten komme den seelen
sind nämlich direkt schon mal in die
hand so dass wir keine lange zeit
verliehen hier vorne ist der durchgang
das funktioniert auch alles und jetzt
brauche ich hier den titel ab und setzte
diesen block durch einem seelen sind das
sollte jetzt alles nach oben gehen hier
den block setzt sich auch wenn so dass
das alles klappt und jetzt müssten wir
eigentlich unbedingt noch ein paar alter
kommen jetzt gar nicht alles aber
erstmal ganz egal
jetzt müssen wir nicht nach oben hin
kommen und deswegen setze ich jetzt auch
hier vorne mal eben schnell den
bruchstein hin und mache auch direkt die
fackeln haben sodass hier vorne direkt
etwas bauen da sehen wir auch schon das
mit dem skelett klappt ich drücke das
jetzt einfach mal mit einer spitzhacke
hier rein sodass wir gucken können und
dass er alles funktioniert also er geht
hier vorne in den gang rein schießt
jetzt jeden moment nach oben genau wie
er hinterher sagt es nach ganz oben
drüber bis zur anderen seite und hier
fällt er nicht runter weil er mir
entgegen schwimmt wahrscheinlich ne und
jetzt fällt er hier rein
[Musik]
in der größte idiot in minecraft je
gesehen hat das kannst du jedoch
wirklich nicht ausdenken ich weiß nicht
wie viele level ich gerade hatte
allerdings sind hier schon das habe ich
glaube ich auch an der tat setzten mit
eingeblendet ich habe ich das loch
schaber zugebaut und ich habe auch hier
vorne
das loch schon zugebaut da muss jetzt
wieder warten dass die erde zu gras wird
so dass ich da den weg dann machen kann
ich weiß nicht wie viele level ich hatte
ich hoffe einfach mal nicht viele
jedoch ist es jetzt eh egal weil ich
habe heute schreibe ich hier
[Musik]
b
und einfach keinen spaß mit diesem
ganzen körper wir schauen nun allerdings
erstmal pressionen alles funktioniert
also wir sehen schon hier unten sind
skelette die spawnen und die werden hier
hochgeschossen und fallen hierunter
dementsprechend gehen wie hier zur seite
gucken wir eben kurz und sehen dass
meine items auf jeden fall doch da sind
zumindest mal eine rüstung ist komplett
noch da die anderen sachen sollten hier
vorne in der kiste drin sein perfekt da
sehen wir schon die ganze steine die da
hinkommen ich nehme die sachen auf jeden
fall mal eben ganz kurz wieder raus und
die benötige ich ja und dann setze ich
hier vor der sommer ganz kurzen in stein
hin ich habe auf jeden fall nur noch
sieben level da seht ihr unsere schon
allerdings sieht hier auch dass die
skelette hier unten auf jeden fall
ankommen also haben schon zwei stück und
wenn ich jetzt einfach theoretisch auch
mit einem stein schlagen würde seht ihr
schon die sterben einfach das heißt ich
brauch nicht mal ein schwert im ganzen
jetzt natürlich wenig lu ting auf meinem
schwer darauf hätte dann würde ich noch
ein paar items mehr bekommen allerdings
seht ihr schon die lassen uns ihre
sachen in dem trichter fallen der
trichter gibt sie hier rein und diese
kiste gibt die hier alt und erst wenn
diese kiste hier voll ist wie diese
kirche befüllt das heißt die schlag
jetzt noch mal es ist tot der knochen
fällt hier rein in den trichter hierüber
in die kiste hier rein und ich kriege
hier erfahrungen ich fühle mich jetzt
hier theoretisch mit autoclick
hinstellen und eine menge erfahrung
sammeln allerdings würde ich sagen dass
wir das demnächst in einigen folgen auf
jeden fall mal zwischendurch so ein
bisschen machen und während ich das hier
mache wollte ich dann auch immer so ein
bisschen fragen beantworten bzw mal ab
und zu eine time labs anwenden also wenn
ihr fragen haben sollte was dieses
projekt jahr gehen schreibt und in die
kommentare wenn die generelle tipps und
vorschläge habt was ich bauen soll was
ich beachten sollte schreibt auch und in
die kommentare in der nächsten folge die
übermorgen online kommen gehen wir mal
endlich wieder in die hölle wir fahren
ein bisschen quatsch wir kümmern uns um
die strandvilla bei hoffentlich die
zweite etage
von daher meine lieben freunde da ist
auch ein neues gerät hier vorne
angekommen das war ganz normal eben
töten von eine freude wenn es euch heute
gefallen hat dann das kann einen daumen
runter video abonniert main kanal und
klickt auf die glocke so dass hier neue
videos nicht verpassen und wir sehen uns
übermorgen wieder um 20 uhr
[Musik]